an announcement when asleep room for
emergency evacuation announcement should
you be required to evacuate Phil Jim
please would you leave the building by
the nearest available exit which is
behind Council I can stall them and
there is one product in this room if you
need to evacuate the room to do so by
the blast door please do hold both
handrails in case the case the stairs
are wet or slippery if anyone is unable
to use the stairs they please allow
others to exit the room before they go
to fire escape door where they can be
given the system's our sembly point will
be in the public car park at the side of
the Civic suite please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff can I please remind you
all to switch off your mobile phones or
turn them to silent thank you um my name
is counselor Joan McPherson does
everybody else in the room know each
other
can I just do a polite round-robin so
everybody can just introduce themselves
if that's okay Michelle Michelle our
committee administrator list of ature
counselor for Mike Lucas kill Michelle
I can I use counselor properly excuse
the state of New York had come straight
from the office independent member thank
you
thank you and non member of this group
whose attentive patient yes yes please
cast anomaly for Rayleigh Grange board
as well - Grange ward and also this
county councillor Thank You Paula she's
first in space Michelle we've got
apologies here from a counselor at mrs.
Mason substituted by counselor and
mysteries mrs. Walker independent person
and councillor Chris Stanley any other
apologies think that takes us onto
supper to your members who I've just
mentioned counselor these rip
substituting counselor mrs. Christine
Mason non-members attending item number
three counselor
thank you and gender item number four
minutes of the last meeting
day two the 27th of March 2019 if those
who attended that meeting can indicate
that they confirm that they're a true
record of that meeting through the grade
lovely thank you yeah
and our main agenda item generator
number 6 member training working group
we're now going to receive a verbal
update from oh sorry mr. item number 5
declarations of interest anybody thank
you gender item number sixth to receive
verbal update from the member training
working group and that will be given by
mr. Sheffield
I believe thank you very much oh we have
a meeting get to be something implies
you trying to start we occasionally are
expected to give instruction to new
counselors more than the older ones but
in general for example planning it's
been ongoing for some time there quite a
few of the counselors complained that
whether they felt sometimes some of the
people that were asked to do the
training really will be put on the
firing line because I had no skills of
training people and I think the
counselors fell over being spoken down
to so that didn't go
very well so after quite a lot of
argument where he had tried to get the
training in place I think there was a
personality clash again one of the
counselors was trying to put it in place
with human resources lady so that didn't
help but the eventual outcome was we had
a meeting Sean and at that meeting
it's a sign that he took him on modeled
easily would be a slight exaggeration
but I think universality the standards
committee had reached the point that it
was going to go wrong at some point with
all the complaints that we had had back
sometimes rather than some written
pieces of paper and some of the
responses we got without training
especially the ones where they had just
picked on
I say playing him because they are
strictly more planning and they felt it
was a complete waste at the time the
planning officer done their best but
they were just wasting their time so the
last Standards Committee eventually got
to the point of saying we've got to
train the people who are doing the
training once we got into Sean and we
pointed out that this was a requirement
because they're employees of the council
and you can't expect your employees just
to take all the slack if it goes wrong
getting the blame for it and they're not
being trained so after about three
quarters of an hour he said you would go
away have a word with the lady in charge
of you
these offices and come up with the best
thing he thought he could and as you've
all found out there now bong in a group
people who will try and set up the
program to train any member of staff or
he's expected to talk to the counselors
I think you've got a look at it see how
the staff feel for every the biggest
problem that I've seen over all the yes
I've been doing is the staff are very
very very knowledgeable the trouble is
it doesn't make them a teacher or a
trainer and a specter sometimes if you
don't really want to be there and
someone's traveling on you eventually
figure out exactly this is all over
so they come away they're not really
taking on board what's being said and
there are one two counselors know better
than the staff anyway so that doesn't
know if you're getting that feedback so
we've got this program starting I think
we've got a wait and see how the staff
feel about it and if possible maybe one
or two of you turn up in the background
of this training I go on occasion if I
can and just see if I'm taking involved
what they're saying I know we have the
problem with counselors but I don't
think they've had that problem with the
staff the ones who want to do it will be
happy to do it
it goes on their CV it increases their
money and it gives them that extra skill
I spoke to Rebecca
I believe she's gone on one maybe last
week and she was only too willing to go
and really that knowledge is terrific
putting that knowledge over a dry
knowledge of the law his type squad pits
to do and keep the counselors interest
so that's where we got to it wasn't as
easy as it sound
Shawn was not over happy that he was
being told by the committee this is
what's got to be put in place but as it
was pointed out I know I say by me no
one else if he doesn't it gives the
committee especially the independent
people the right to go along to the
council and say you're not hitting what
we should be eating as a council you're
putting on trying people up to train
someone and when it goes for him it will
be down to you because you're the head
of the council and I think he had a word
with HR and it seems to be moving in the
right direction
contains a two-hour meeting don't thank
you just before we open for questions
could be just a minute
our thanks to the working group for
everything they've done on that project
thank you yes Lucas girl thank you Karen
should we be asking for fairly regular
reports on how this is going I think
we've got to see how the first couple go
and there is nothing stopping the
Chairman on the self and the working
committee actually asking the members of
staff who were being tried if they're
happy with the training as it helped if
it doesn't help them the gallery think
it was this point is carrying on with
something there's always the time any
member can go and sit in the background
I mean I occasionally attend I've got a
training meeting just because I'm
entitled to
it comes across one time to me and I'm
not the brightest of people if I can get
me interesting than the ones that are
doing it for the job should be untied so
yes I'd give you one or two training
sessions first before we put something
in place that counts lasers thank you
touched on there something again they're
the tasks and the last question about
the you think that counselors could turn
up to these training meetings to
actually just see what goes on how are
we going to know about that is this
going to be circulated to counselors as
something they can turn up to are we
going to get a program of events that's
up to you think through your chairman
they've just got two events organized at
the moment and all council should have
had an email yeah I think it's detailing
what the exactly is in contained in the
program there to date set those members
of staff for being allocated to the
sessions okay yeah I've seen that don't
send me an email saying training has
been set out and I didn't ask the
question penny counts of Jordans fluid
in the sessions of those training so I
did ask that coaching minutes came
another stand if I wanted to make sure
that you were aware of what was going on
did you run the race anything counts at
this point yeah I mean come on I do only
if you've finished that was hard to talk
about the training in general but if you
finish it what you was I'd say there's a
few more questions and then oh okay yeah
the only way I was I turning up to the
training session you would be in the
cinema rather than taking part because
they're gonna try the obvious one they
Rebecca Roos going
I've always been to one I mean she's
fully trained as a lawyer so she knows
how to be the sober you couldn't really
join in that you
I just have to sit there the woods use
any expectation of joining maybe of just
what as you say and then say if the
people that have been trying counselor
mrs. couldn't it's interesting that you
mention one particular officer because I
actually had session with her for the
licensing the other day and I did note
while I was there that she had done some
really good try you previously with
licensing and she has a very good way of
coming across a nothing or even if did
at there and she obviously is very
gifted and interesting and that's that
Charlize because everything she tells
you she puts in the terminology for us
to on the stage which is great and
follow-up could only recommend um I've
got a couple questions in one second
first of all we the the training the
train the trainer training which is some
quick title for it and the two sessions
actually happened today I'm an email was
circulated I think it was really to make
us aware you know as opposed to
attending a couple of things I noted you
mentioned about them being happy with
the training the staff I think the way
that from train the trainer training you
will find out if it's working from the
evaluation and working out how much the
learners have gained in those that will
be the measure of a good training sense
stay
again Commission you mentioned them all
the complaints so were they from the
same without home you know divulge in
anybody's names from the same sort of
area or the same courses because you
highlighted on planning or not but we
have a lot of different training him
there was a few on training I have a few
comments there was quite a few about the
white meetings have been chaired and
that's where we've had a hell of a
bottle official complaints the not
necessarily gone before level but I've
been picked up by Angela and I'm sure
Angela has the opportunity and she's
making it a point of fact you know where
if it's a complaint that you think and
she asked the independent members to
view that complaint and she takes it in
turn so we get a fair spread of
complaints and the reason for that as
well if the complaint goes before length
anybody who sat in on the complaint in
the beginning cannot see at the end okay
no he's talking here about complaints
about training or are we talking about
complaints it can be about anything I
think mine was specific I'm justifying
some well on the training is usually
comments written or may be said by the
counselors who have turned up we've had
a few on planet they are usually from
holder counselors older is in length of
time that one
and in some instances I would counselors
who are not happy it's the same old
thing that type of now that wasting nets
I we had one or two and I'm not sure why
they are licensed in most of the
complaints arm planning whether it's up
to date especially the last life was to
do with the travelers there was and a
lot of them are needles a lot of them is
because quite a few counselors don't
particularly most of the trained and the
younger counselors I think awesome but I
say younger newer counselors sometimes
feel intimidated by what's going on
that's all we've had one or two other
heavy complaints and they're usually
from the same people which is all I can
really say on them and you have to put
experience me yeah but you still got to
take that on board because if something
goes wrong like you did on one and the
traveling of beatings it then started to
get quite heavy plane from just I didn't
know I wasn't told and then it starts
getting out and that's the sort of
skills that they will be gaining in this
training we hope so yeah are there any
more questions now one of the issues
that I had a concern over here's some of
the training that we have his mandatory
is you're fully aware and some of that
to be on this can be quite repetitive
especially around something like
planning because apart from the new
policy you will be going over they
everything that I new counselor has to
claim but I have some concerns when
there's he's not proposition
because we're training these guys to
have the skills how staff to have the
skills to deliver this training and then
if counselors don't attend them they
will then be offered a mop-up session
there is no way shape or form that that
can be as good as the training for the
two and a half three hour sessions that
we sit through but one of my main
concerns is as with the train the Train
are we're going to have more efficient
training which therefore will hopefully
make us more efficient in our decision
making
therefore Maureen condom economical for
our counsel but putting on mop-up
sessions cost and I don't like button on
things like that that's going to cross
down council and this actually happened
last week so I actually invited the
chairman of Licensing along to explain
last week's session if you would like to
Westham yeah I want to rig up the issue
of mandatory training last year a
subcommittee was set up within standards
to look at the training within our DC as
it was felt it needed to be streamlined
correctly and improved weight training
was given and to make sure all moment
train was across the board for all
counselors the subcommittee as I was one
of those members
I felt as extremely good job had sorted
out the training and coming up with
ideas train the Train and being able to
deliver the correct training within the
time frankly flight especially for the
new fiscal year I was therefore very
disappointed to see that only 11
counselors out of the firm out of 15
attended the mandatory training one
counselor being a substitute for
licensing which I may end was a
three-hour session albeit with a small
break I would like to state that a man
to do training course for committees
like licensing appeals and development
planning are essential criteria
who wishes to sit on a hearing with
regards to a particular aspect
I cannot therefore understand those
members who have requested to sit on
these committees but were not able to
attend this mandatory training as there
was plenty of notice given for this
training course we all have other
commitments and some of us have jobs
whether full-time or part-time but make
sure these did not interfere with this
mandatory training course I do also
understand that any counselor can sit on
any committee even if they are not a
member but cannot always vote I am also
on the understand yin and a mop-up
session for this training course may be
provided which I will be discussing with
our leader that's something else I do
not believe that any mandatory training
that is not fulfilled by a counselor
should be substituted by a mop-up
session this is a mockery of our
training required by each Council and we
go to great lengths to provide 45
trainers at a cost of the council and I
feel that a mop-up session is and will
be inadequate and another expense of the
council Thank You chairman Thank You
councillor Esther so I'm a new chairman
of this group but I'm looking at
pragmatically in my opinion the person
who has the mop-up training does not
receive as good a training which I have
to say is exceptional last week by our
person who's just done the trainer
training course it's not going to be as
good so they're not going to make as
good in my opinion decisions as those
who have had the intensive training so
I'm going to I've got a few ideas but
I'm going to open it to the floor if
anybody's got some comments questions
suggestions all we've got hangs up
councillor is first can I just clarify
when we actually have these training
sessions am i right in thinking that we
have the option of
during the day or the evening courses in
every case I don't think that that's
available in every case okay and we do
have how much how many months notice do
we have because we're talking what's a
month now June 2 and these come out with
some pre elections so if people have
been standing last year they already
know the days chairman if I may just
come in there
the licensing training I had to cancel
an outside appointment because there was
only the one session and I started at
one o'clock on that day yeah yep I think
yes I know I took a day off but it's not
about personal circumstances for this is
to explore a way forward from this one
and sorry counselor mrs. Roy human eggs
yeah I just wanted to sky I mean I work
Monday to Friday
yeah and when we have give me six-month
life whether you give me a year's notice
I'm still not gonna be able to get it
was I out unless it's done in me no it's
not as easy to get day off as as you
might think but there's no way that I
could give a year's notice and I still
wouldn't be able to take that out and
just just an aside if you are wanting to
do a training session and there isn't
one at a time to suitable for you ie in
the evening do you feed that into member
services and ask that question no I have
I think I might done one from my 16
something when I was nicely you know I
did that once but now I happen okay and
cats for mrs. kidding I was just gonna
say the reason licensed in training is
during the day is because all the
licensing which is I held you in the day
son
being his wife as opposed to planning
which is an option of day or evening
because the planning is held annually I
tell you I do understand but it does
seem to restrict certain members from
being able to accept the training if we
are looking at putting it on all the
time during the day is there an option
that we could consider that would be
instead of putting on during the day if
it's just one session
it goes on in the evening and that would
I think then it takes all the excuses
out of it because I think you know I
understand cancer always position
although I run my own business and I do
run my own life if it effectively there
are commitments that I have in my
business that sometimes I can't get away
during the day but in the evening I am
always free okay so it's the only thing
with that isn't it isn't relevant to me
but some people do work evenings as well
I mean I know when I know in my working
life and I was often working evenings so
that doesn't you know if you can't just
assume that people worker a nine-to-five
daytime job I would understand what
you're saying but yeah I would suggest
that that probably exception rather than
the rope most most of you may be because
their employment would be not be able to
make it but it's not in I'm just
thinking it as an option if this is
becoming a problem and you're thinking
that the mop-up sessions aren't good
enough then would it be an idea to ask
the members all the members in the
council as to whether if there was just
one session would it be more suitable to
run it later in the day rather than
during the day just audio I have some
ideas but I will come back to them
Council mr. tiefer
I mean if not you say some people
working in your junk I sit there and I
work during the day can't you put two
it may be the cost if we look at the
cost as well but what but these are
things to explore I think we're getting
a bit bogged down here about my means of
sessions and I think the real issue here
is about the licensing and peels
training if I'm right here and clearly
people if members can't attend daytime
sessions for training they're never
going to be able to attend a licensing
hearing so from where I sit I have never
put myself on a licensing appeals
committee because I know that I wouldn't
be able to fulfill that and I think its
members have to be obviously
understandably members work and work at
different times and they have other
commitments but then I I don't
understand why a member who had such
commitments would put themselves on such
a committee how to take the training I
will just say um I took him a days and
you leave to attend the training and
then we did have a quick call in for an
appeal on Tuesday thank you today and I
took the day off in as well holiday but
that's my choice because that's my
commitment to counselling Siskin I'm
just going to mention er see no good
idea there was hundred June's or is it
exactly the same nothing macerate it's
just in the context of what we're being
asked to consider here we're not being
asked to consider one committee this is
all committees and I was just I'm just
pointing out that this is this is
something that affects all committees so
yes I think the elimination to the
specific mention by the licensing
committee and I think again just
supporting that and this is mandatory
and we knew a long time in advance get
this message out
and if we go back we're rigidly started
the two committees that are if you want
the most likely to go wrong and so
therefore any counselor certainly should
be fully aware of the law his planning
and licensing and this is the politics
of it where we have these silly
arguments
nobody should sit on a committee that
can bring the council into disrepute and
cost a fortune
yeah if they're not trying that we
tickled about with this over the years
but the original suggestion and it
sounds funny came from the independent
members that if you haven't been tried
you can't sit on that committee now
anything else doesn't come into it if
you can't sign up because of your job
but don't sit on that committee because
where are you going wrong it's no excuse
for I weren't trained you've got the
police involved on the licensing one you
get an appeal because of somebody's made
a silly comment or a silly statement and
the one that really lightened it up
we this is a long while ago but it will
show you how stupid it was
we had counselors at the time that just
turn up and sat on the committee
concluding the conversations we actually
asked them you know what you do what you
think of this what you think of that and
one of them kept refusing extended
licensing hours he never gave the reason
it just didn't want extended license in
there and just out of the blue
you've got an interest so I said you
know you miss committee I said pardon
your Salvation Army so how can you sit
on there and not be biased he could not
with a normal bid but he definitely just
stopped them and we lost hundreds of
bits and pieces because it didn't take
long for all the licensees to read it
poppers that seen on this committee was
someone who was auntie dreaming and so
we had to slowly pull him out and at
that point the cameras all said no come
on you all got to know the rules
you've got to declare an interest and if
you harm somebody who is religious one
way away then you cannot sit on that
committee - all the decision if the
training had been good enough and that's
where we went so now I honestly believe
I can't make the decisions anymore but
no one should sit on a committee if they
are not trained
planning isn't one that could cost the
council of fortune the licensing is one
that goes wrong very quickly and most of
the licensing ones are here with during
the day so you have to be aware that if
you don't attend it then you shouldn't
be on it I'm not forgetting especially
licensing unless everyone so correct me
it's often at short notice as well um
look I've had an idea because I have
mentioned it to them councilor wisdom we
have local authorities that provide
training if for some reason that
somebody and we have to still decide
what a valid reason ease cannot attend
training they could attend training at
one of our local authorities but I don't
think it should be in the cost of his
council councillors have an allowance
and if they want to attend that meeting
and be on that committee
then they could pay for their own
training if they're unable to attend
that's just an idea then I like it but I
don't think it would go down to a month
the Standards Committee makes the
decisions whether it goes down but or
not it's the standards that you set for
the council and it is supposed to be
non-political so basically if you make
that better standards for this council
mandatory check mandatory training is
just that and that would give people the
opportunity to attend training and you
know if they've got to it they've got to
go to training one way or the other and
they can't go whatever reason to the
training that's been provided then an
alternative could be found but would
have to be very expensive so I'll go
back to this mock-up sessions again I
think you mentioned it Joe I just don't
feel up session for half an hour or an
hour and taking the time where they are
obvious because they might be digital we
had a very experienced barrister who
knew all the ins and outs of whatever
and I don't believe me do a session for
a very important thing I've either
observer development or licensing
because we are there to represent our
residents we are there to make sure the
decisions we make are correct for how
areas could be to do with the chatbox
said to do with licensing for drinks and
whatever so we've got to really be
careful when we go again it's down to
the subcommittee or the stands of the
Standards Committee and how you want to
take that forward
that proposal second day yeah when you
say them pay for the mop-up do you mean
the session at another authority I've
seen you you mean a proper session at a
session yet another authority yeah yeah
full full training training so that we
know is it's a good standard it also be
a daytime training session of course
good I'm German so I suggest that
there's a rider there that if they don't
perform either they or exclude you from
the committee I don't have a problem
with anybody I can see I've seen a
summation is it does it make them they
cannot they're not they can come on a
committee they claim come to the
committee and seat and opt fund so I
don't know where they converts or not
there is something I think they'd have
to speak to even come like they've comes
them in committee and make a
representation or whatever but I'm not
showing the aspect of whether they can
vote on the committee that I think
wanted to come into this committee and
I'm not sure how that I just wonder
helmet how valid their comment would be
if they haven't had the training well
yep please and the the ruling is that
they can be a member of the licensing
committee even if they haven't had the
training because it's to do with policy
if it would just be policy as it would
be with any other committee but it's the
hearings that they were excluded from if
they don't attend the training so they
can't be used to attend hearings right
will they be able to vote on on the
committee
so again I'm can you not can't stand
just not say they can come to the
committee but if they haven't done the
training they can't miss every vote I
don't know he's just to my position a
policy change it was able to go to
Council in 2017 and it just confirmed
that the requirement to attend mandatory
licensing committee training each year
be mandatory only in respect of enabling
members to sit on licensing hearings and
that members of the licensing committee
who do not attend mandatory licensing
criteria should remain as voting members
of the licensing committee sorry yes
there was something but not from what
you said but I I because there's the
likelihood that there may only be sort
of out of the whole committee three
people available on the particular day
when a hearing is necessary but it was
essential that every member of the
committee was trained to be able to be
selected for a panel for the who yeah
well it does reduce the pool if you
haven't got considerable akin yeah I
mean could I ask if you can make up of
that committee is cross-party possibly
of what committee of the licensing of
the hearings or the captial committee
itself that is pro rata just as any
committee can I just say that one
opposition man that came to the Train at
all
so in theory you know it's a big concern
you feel if it's meant to be provide to
be promoted I said I hope you won't know
so we are we should mention it this is
getting quite wide is this something for
the working group I think you get how
many would be better taken to the
working group and then referring back
and yes can I say you need to set up a
working group for my new one less than
your next item but I did look across to
you because I would think your points
about how valid it is to have the
complete training certain definitely
physical I'll just make a comment
because looking back over the years when
all these lives have changed every time
we get new counselors and new ideas but
the initial idea of compulsory training
came up in the main proper area and it
works and still until people start
fiddling knowing that the end result is
ignoring the politics of it if you want
to sit as most councils don't on the
planning committee if you haven't had
good schooling in what you kind of do it
will go wrong and it has gone wrong over
the years luckily no say luckily this
council has never really got into deep
water but we know if you
the planning one is exactly the same you
end up in cold you all would end up
looking silly and then it comes out I
didn't really know what I was talking
about you can't do that
so I think that you as a convincing it's
not a sin
and we we have a good record we want to
maintain net do therefore we need to
tighten up on this training and who's
going to know just my skeleton the last
couple of planning meetings that are
trying to hop into have been absolutely
exemplary yeah I have been really very
ok so and that will take us nicely on to
determine the membership of the working
group for 2019-20 who would like to be
on my working group in of the meetings
[Laughter]
we need on we had for last time and it
went you did go to council and it was it
comprised of cross group membership so
there was a representative from each
group on it because it was dealing with
training for the whole of the council
right okay and that for last time what
happened independent side is that I was
the main one but we will take it in
turns if there's something that another
independent member feels they want to
have any apple into so yes you can put
me down as the main one it effectively
yellow light rather improvement to that
think we do that because you have no
control over us whatsoever
now you can send someone else along to
come up with a different point of you
know running amok folk
we've got no control the missus like yes
I went up when she had the lady when
were they held last year we had early
evening today be certified by the club
the money that's suta difficult yeah so
we have got counselor mr. Lucas kill our
Vice Chair counselor mrs. June nominee
mr. Schad bow stroke and counselor mrs.
Hawaii everybody uses hoist Academy said
mrs. rice and for did you say we had for
last time mrs. hoy this is why mr.
Chappelle show
mr. Chappelle wouldn't be counted as one
of our writing he's just to have claimed
out for input
yeah so that be if it's cross-party
counselor mrs. Mason yes we have gone
counselor Stanley as well haven't we are
on the I'll come on if you want to keep
saying it yes not a flea
honestly I'm learning to be or nice well
I think the point I made made there is
the liberal group it is and then it
doesn't have to be just for people that
was just what was decided last so we
could have fire we did have it cross
group last time do we do it
are we expected to it would be you could
have fun but you have to mean
have you and then have three others
right um counselor mr. Lucas Gill
counselor mrs lammle counselor mrs.
Hawaii counselor mr. Stanley and
counselor mrs. Macy Samuel finds his
chin so pretty everyone that we have our
independent members who will be there as
well to stop our members running amok
has anybody got any further questions
I'd like to just raise one thing yeah
it's back really to what you're saying
about having members pay for training
with the authorities has it actually
been explored with other authorities
whether that's going to be available not
yet but we have done in the past I had
the option to do training or even joint
training I'm going back a few years but
let's see what's what the options are
out there anything that saves our budget
in our purse is good for me so we're
fine down Thank You anybody ask me other
questions and I declare the me - no
thank you